[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing harry
potter the boy who lived and a rather
disturbing instance in which he's able
to effectively use crucio the torture
curse now we talk quite early on that
the unforgivable curses are hard to use
largely due to the fact that they are
horrible spells that require genuine
intent for them to work properly in this
case we're discussing crucio or the
cruciatus curse which is arguably the
hardest one to wield without proper
intent crucio literally translates to by
torture in latin so you can already
begin to get an idea of what this spell
does
crucio is most often used by dark
witches and wizards and a known
proponent of crucio is bellatrix the
strange who used it to torture alice and
frank longbottom
when cast crucio inflicts excruciating
pain on the victim
pain so excruciating that it is
considered to be torturous casting
crucio is said to require a wand and
incantation and its effects are said to
vary depending on the caster's desires
and emotions to produce the excruciating
pain implied by the name the caster must
despise the victim and enjoy causing
pain
harry potter after crucio was cast on
him described it as feeling like his
head was being split open while having
his bone set on fire but harry hasn't
just been on the receiving end of crucio
evidently our boy wonder has actually
attempted to use crucio on numerous
occasions which is awfully surprising
considering harry is well good and this
spell tortures people the first time
harry attempts to use crucio is on
bellatrix estrange following the tragic
death of sirius ah did you love him
little baby potter hatred rose and harry
such as he had never known before he
flung himself up from behind the
fountain and bellowed crucio bellatrix
screamed the spell had knocked her off
her feet but she did not rise and shriek
with pain as neville had she was already
back on her feet breathless no longer
laughing harry dodged behind the golden
fountain again her counter-spell hit the
head of the handsome wizard which was
blown off and landed 20 feet away
gouging long scratches into the wooden
floor
never used an unforgivable curse before
have you boy she yelled she'd abandoned
her baby voice now
you need to mean them potter you need to
really want to cause pain to enjoy it
righteous anger won't hurt me for long
i'll show you how it is done shall i
i'll give you a lesson harry was edging
around the fountain on the other side
when she screamed crucio and he was
forced to duck down again as the
centaur's arm holding its bow
spun off and landed with a crash on the
floor a short distance from the golden
wizard's head as you can see from the
passage above when harry tried to use it
on bellatrix it just didn't work that
well and the reason simply boils down to
the fact that he just wasn't sinister
enough to use it effectively even with
the fresh death of sirius harry did not
have enough hate in his heart to torture
bellatrix which is why i think it's
quite disturbing that not long after
harry was able to use the spell to its
full extent on death eater amicus caro
it's not a case of what you'll permit
minerva mcgonagall your time's over it's
us what's in charge here now and you'll
back me up before you'll pay the price
and he spat in her face harry pulled the
cloak off himself raised his wand and
said you shouldn't have done that as
amicus spun around harry shouted crucio
the death eater was lifted off his feet
he writhed through the air like a
drowning man thrashing and howling in
pain
and then with the crunch and the
shattering of glass he smashed into the
front of a bookcase and crumpled
insensible to the floor i see what
bellatrix meant said harry the blood
thundering through his brain you need to
really mean it
this passage always confused me because
while spitting in mcgonagall's face is
certainly grounds for some kind of
reaction from harry the torture curse
always seemed a bit extreme furthermore
how come harry was unable to wield it
after something incredibly dire like the
death of sirius but completely able
after something comparably innocent
expelliarmus would have been completely
appropriate in this moment but harry
chose to harness his hate and torture
someone so what gives how did this
happen was it because harry was a more
experienced wizard or is it because his
difficult life led to his ability to
harness hatred does this mean that harry
is not as good of a person as we may
have previously thought is this mostly
glossed over altercation actually one of
the darkest moments in the series there
are two possible explanations here one
harry genuinely did have hatred in his
heart and he was just embracing it
after all that harry had endured over
the years he simply became jaded and by
effectively using the torture curse he
was tapping into his new darker side
this would suggest that harry is maybe
not as pure as we initially thought
or two there is a distinction between
enjoying it and meaning it we're taught
by bellatrix who's not the most reliable
source the casting crucio requires you
to both mean it and enjoy it but i think
that the second requirement stated by
bellatrix is more of a romanticism than
anything she was inexplicably twisted
after all
i think the curse simply requires intent
meaning and in this instance harry was
able to wield the necessary intent to
cast the curse while the fact remains
that torturing someone is awful and
while harry could have just used another
spell in this particular predicament i
don't think that harry's use of the
spell necessarily means that harry
enjoyed it he simply saw a purpose for
it and wielded pure unadulterated intent
this does bring up another question
though why wasn't harry able to
effectively use the spell years earlier
harry knew what crucio was when he cast
it on bellatrix the first time so he
must have known that it required intent
why didn't it work that time was it
simply because he was a younger less
experienced wizard i think that this
boils down to a few things one harry
actually was less experienced the first
time harry tried to use the spell was
well the first time he tried to use the
spell becoming good at something
requires repetition and magic is not
excluded from this principle
why do you think harry is such an expert
at expelliarmus
two a lot going on sirius black harry's
godfather that he'd only just recently
rekindled his relationship with was just
killed by bellatrix harry still young
and having only witnessed death on a few
occasions was likely overcome with
emotion
sadness shock disgust anger these are
likely just a few of the emotions that
harry was overcome by
so it stands to reason that harry's
ability to focus in on just one of these
emotions effectively anger hatred would
have been inhibited his emotions were
simply all over the place so i'm not
surprised that he wasn't able to torture
someone in the case of mcgonagall it was
a much more controlled environment he
knew who caro was there was no real
pressure for him to act there and then
and carrow spitting in mcgonagall's face
was able to elicit a feeling of pure
rage in harry which he was able to
harness mcgonagall being spat on didn't
make him sad it made him angry which
made crucio the perfect weapon in this
moment
what do you guys think was harry's
ability to use crucio the result of pure
unadulterated and most importantly
harnessed rage did it harry enjoy
torturing karo does this scene
demonstrate a distinct lack of innocence
in harry's character leave a comment
down below with what you think and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
until next time remember happiness can
be found even in the darkest of times if
one only remembers to turn on the light
you